so my first question for the both of you
and um Taylor you can go first and then
Alia afterwards
um what were the best and worst things
about the pods I think the best was that
we were able to build emotional
connections
um you know we didn't get to see what
the other person looked like and that
was that was awesome
um
the worst thing
it was fast but it was fast in a good
way so I don't I don't like I don't have
anything bad to say about I don't have
any negative comments you know for me
the best part was just
um being like the
the environment of being in the pods is
so different because it it removes all
the distraction that the world would
kind of normally kind of place on us
when we're dating outside of that sort
of environment of the pods so I liked
that it felt like we could really like
Zone into the people we were dating I
liked that it felt very intimate
um
and I mean I don't think there was
anything bad about that but I'll just
say like it was sort of hard at the same
time not having
the things that you're used to leaning
on for Comfort like you know it's it's
you don't have your your your mom and
dad or your best friend to just hey girl
I just met this man and you can't do
that so that's that's a little hard yeah
you know it's it's good and they're
they're like pros and cons to that
you're just like okay this is great I
can just focus on you but then it's like
man
I'm in here all by my lonesome
so yeah yeah that makes sense usually
when you're talking to someone you want
to be like oh my gosh hey let me text
this person immediately
I all the way through loved my whole
experience
um obviously heartbreak is never fun but
you grow from it and I wouldn't I
wouldn't take it back I I loved
everything from falling in love all the
way to the Heartbreak wouldn't change
anything at all yeah
um
I mean it's it's it's hard to say when
you ask me the best thing about the pods
I mean
the way I saw it I'm like well I'm
hanging out with a great group of guys
I'm talking to beautiful women I'm
eating great food like I mean that right
there just
the whole experience is amazing
um the worst
I probably should have packed more
clothes
but that one's on me
because you don't think about that
you're like I'm not seeing the other
person what do I have to you know my
bike took off I packed the same morning
that my flight took off and it was just
like throw everything in the bag like
I had just gotten off of work yeah I
didn't think that one through so that's
what's in the T-shirt I'm good
oh Chris I still have your jacket
jacket is I found it in my closet the
other day and I was like it's a medium
yeah I don't know how you pulled that
one off but
so glad I'm able to
the history fantastic thank you
so one last question for both of you
um above all what have you learned about
love
in this experiment love is hard
it's not easy
um but like Alia said earlier like you
do have to follow your gut your heart
and if it feels off like you know you
can love somebody and still not be with
that person
um I think that's so important to
remember
um
I mean for anybody and like that's stuck
in my brain from here on out because I
did have love for JP but it wasn't right
and so that's why I walked away yeah
yeah I mean pretty much the same for me
um yeah I mean it's important to just
know like you know love is very
complicated it's a journey it's it's one
of those emotions that I think we're all
still trying to figure out even after we
can fill it and we're like man this is
the strongest thing I've ever
experienced it's still very mysterious
and it's still very difficult to
navigate at times so it's not perfect
it's not white black and white you know
it's it's very complex and we have to
Grant each other Grace and navigating
love because it's it's difficult
sometimes I learned it's kind of the
same answer love and about myself is
in order to find love and find the per
the right person for you you have to be
open and honest about who you are as a
person and give your full self and you
know if that's not what they want and
what they're looking for then that's
fine you're a perfect person no matter
what you like and that's how you find
the person that matches you yeah I would
I would agree with that I think for for
me also you know you know love is
complex love is Nuance love is intricate
love evolves it changes it's it's a
constant thing that you you have to work
on like it's it's not a One-Stop type of
thing
um you know I I compared it to like
undergrad or earlier
um you know that's what love is like for
me you know there's some semesters that
are going to be better than others and
then it's hey sometimes you have to look
at your schedule and say okay I'm about
to take organic chemistry on top of
thermodynamics on top of physics too
I should probably take a music theory
you know it's understanding the balance
and how to juggle the multiple things in
life that's what love that is one thing
I've learned coming out of the pods it's
balance I like that I like that answer
that's good can't relate on the any of
the science stuff because I got it with
you but I'm with you
yeah maybe maybe thermodynamics is your
easy class
I didn't even know
okay
that makes me feel a little better all
right well um thank you both so much for
your time today I really appreciate the
opportunity to talk to you
um I wish you well on your adventures
and yeah have a wonderful day